[Music]
it's natural for movies based on true
stories to embellish events a little bit
but in the case of sound of Freedom
bending the truth might just cause more
harm than good it's no secret that sound
of Freedom presents a sensationalized
version of human trafficking after all
the movie needs to set up a plot that
will hit all the usual action movie
beats so naturally its traffickers are
shadowy villains who swoop in and snatch
children away from their families the
movie's opening actually starts with a
montage of security camera footage
showing literal shadowy figures grabbing
children off the street the sad truth is
that most victims of trafficking aren't
attacked by total strangers and whisked
Away into the night instead as the
office for the assistant Secretary of
planning and evaluation reports they are
usually manipulated over a period of
time by someone they know whether that
be a family member friend or partner the
most prevalent kind of trafficking is
neither dramatic nor cinematic it makes
sense that sound of Freedom would
emphasize this significantly rarer kind
of trafficking however people need to
understand that the movies presentation
of trafficking isn't accurate it's less
important to be worried about strangers
on the streets than it is to be watching
for subtle signs of emotional and
physical abuse from close friends and
loved ones there's no denying that human
trafficking is a serious worldwide
problem but people need to have a proper
understanding of the problem in order to
address it sound of Freedom doesn't just
misconstrue how human trafficking
typically happens it also seriously
misrepresents who the victims of
trafficking tend to be the film centers
around the case of two young siblings
sold into the sex trade in fact almost
all the victims depicted in the film are
children but that's not exactly true to
life
child
five to ten times a day in reality the
aspe office reports that victims of
trafficking are just as likely to be
sold as laborers if not more for this
reason people of all genders and ages
can be trafficked what's more
trafficking victims also don't
exclusively come from outside the United
States when it comes to child
trafficking specifically most victims
still don't match the movie's
representation most children who are
trafficked are adolescents or teenagers
with the majority falling between the
ages of 15 and 17. they often come from
underrepresented communities and many of
them are lgbtq and find themselves taken
in by traffickers after being kicked out
of their homes a minority of trafficking
victims are young children and the sad
truth is that of those victims their
parents are often complicit in their
trafficking just like the movie's
representation of how trafficking Works
its depiction of victims make sense in a
cinematic context audiences are going to
have a deeply emotional response to
seeing young children as trafficking
victims in the film but once again
understanding the truth about
trafficking is a prerequisite to
addressing the problem in the real world
both in the film and in reality Tim
Ballard worked as a Department of
Homeland Security agent before going
rogue to rescue trafficking victims in
that role Ballard's job was less about
finding children and more about catching
perpetrators early in the film Ballard
has something of a crisis of faith and
starts taking a new initiative in his
work Ballard pretends to be a pedophile
to get close to Ernst oshinsky a man he
just arrested ashinski eventually leads
Ballard to another man named Earl
Buchanan who purchased Miguel after the
boy was stolen from his family at the
beginning of the movie after separating
Miguel from Buchanan Ballard takes the
young boy out for burgers and promises
that he'll find his sister the real
Buchanan however was not a child
trafficker instead he was arrested for
possessing and transporting child
pornography later being charged with
child molestation by state officials as
well obviously as the hero of what's
ostensibly an action movie Ballard needs
plenty of opportunities to take things
into his own hands in real life it's
doubtful he did so much solo work with
perpetrators while working for Homeland
Security what's more as former
Department of Justice employee Aaron
Albright told Rolling Stone Ballard's
dinner with Miguel would never happen as
no agent would be allowed to be alone
with a victim in a setting like that
Miguel is arguably the most important
character in sound of freedom of course
Tim Ballard's conflicted thoughts about
his job with the DHS lead him to meet
Miguel but it was the young boy's story
that drove Ballard to becoming vigilante
trafficking hunter in the film Ballard
first meets Miguel while arresting Earl
Buchanan and the young boy gives Ballard
a necklace from his sister Rocio and
begs Ballard to try and find his sister
while sound of Freedom needed to take
some liberties with the true story for
cinematic purposes most viewers will
probably be shocked to learn that almost
every detail of Miguel's story was
completely fabricated for the movie
everything from Miguel's kidnapping to
his connection with Ballard was entirely
different in real life independent
Watchdog American Crime Journal
investigated Buchanan's arrest and found
the details to be wildly different from
what sound of Freedom presents Buchanan
was crossing from Mexico into the United
States with a young boy when he was
captured but Ballard wasn't present for
the arrest furthermore Buchanan wasn't
any kind of suspect when he made the
border crossing but he didn't have the
child with whom he was traveling's birth
certificate on him so border patrol
agents searched his vehicle they found a
videotape of Buchanan sexually abusing
the child and arrested him Ballard only
got involved because he was sent by DHS
to collect the tape the biggest change
that sounded Freedom made to the true
story though is adding Miguel's sister
into the plot and if this was your
daughter
in real life Buchanan's victim's sister
was back at home with her family when
Buchanan was arrested and she never
ended up being trafficked herself
journalists and human trafficking
experts didn't need to uncover every
inaccuracy and sound of Freedom there
are some details in the movie that the
filmmakers readily admit were invented
for the story for example though the
character of Vampiro is based on a real
person the most important parts of his
backstory in the film are fictional in
the movie Vampiro becomes an important
partner in Ballard's mission to save
child trafficking victims the reformed
criminal formally spent time in jail and
even more importantly he once hired
someone he thought was a sex worker only
to discover later that she was 14 years
old Vampiro was disgusted with himself
and decided to start working on behalf
of trafficking victims Angel Studios the
distributor behind sound of Freedom
published a blog post comparing some of
the film's details to the true story
according to the post Vampiro never
spent any time in jail and he never
slept with an underage girl his entire
motivation in the movie was made up as
was his real involvement with Ballard
the post explains that Vampiro didn't
actually work with Ballard on the
mission depicted in the film though he
did work with Ballard and operation
Underground Railroad on a different rate
in Colombia the ending of sound of
Freedom gives us the film's most
noticeable embellishment on the true
story in his attempt to find Rocio
Ballard leads in operation in Colombia
that recovers over 50 child trafficking
victims the filmmakers claim that the
real-life version of the mission ended
up saving 123 trafficking victims though
not all of them were children after the
operation the rest of the movie leaves
reality behind in the film Tim doesn't
find Rocio among the other children but
he refuses to give up on his promise to
Miguel he and Vampiro discovered that
the girl was sold to a group that lives
deep in an unmapped jungle he saw real
territory no one goes in on the Army on
the police not us almost any visitors to
the area will be killed upon arrival so
Ballard and Vampiro disguise themselves
as doctors to successfully sneak into
the camp as far as action movie climaxes
go Ballard's charge into the jungle is
pretty compelling it's also entirely
made up in real life Balor never made a
solo plunge into a dangerous jungle to
save a child trafficking victim
furthermore the Excursion Ballard was a
part of that involved posing as a U.N
doctor did not lead to any rescued
children we've already seen that the
movie's representation of Ballard story
and trafficking as a whole is much
larger than life so it shouldn't come as
much of a surprise that the film's
dramatic conclusion isn't part of the
true story
sound of Freedom puts plenty of effort
into transforming Tim Ballard into an
action hero he's depicted as a man
willing to do anything to save children
and he seems to be the only person ready
to face the reality of how brutal that
work can be during Ballard's jungle
Excursion at the end of the movie he
even shoots a man before finally saving
Rocio in the movie Ballard's killing
comes across as completely Justified and
even heroic in real life an
extrajudicial killing like that would
come with some massive moral and legal
implications that's probably why in its
blog post addressing the film's relation
to reality Angel Studios noted Tim
Ballard is committed to rescuing
children and operates within the
boundaries of the law collaborating with
local authorities and governments to
combat child trafficking the real
Ballard has never killed anyone and if
he had it would have been illegal having
Ballard kill someone in the film's
climax might make sense for an action
movie but it's another example of how
sound of Freedom shows a distorted
version of human trafficking the problem
with this presentation is that it might
convince some viewers that the solution
to trafficking is a rugged individual
willing to do anything real life experts
agree that actual solutions to
trafficking look more like government
programs put in place to support runaway
children poor families parents
struggling with addictions and migrants
who might be seen as easier targets for
manipulation and abuse
the movie caps off its Story by making
some pretty bold claims about human
trafficking at the end of the film title
cards appear with captions explaining
how the human trafficking industry
raises 150 billion dollars annually and
that more people are being enslaved now
than at any point in human history human
trafficking is a serious and horrifying
problem that needs to be addressed but
neither of those claims gives audiences
the best impression of reality
trafficking is estimated to generate
roughly 150 billion dollars in profits
each year but that number has very
little to do with the context of the
movie The majority of trafficking
victims aren't young children nor are
they sold into the sex trade instead
most of that money comes from Forced
labor in all fairness sound of Freedom
isn't the only source to claim that more
humans are slaves today than at any
other point in history The Guardian made
the same claim in a 2019 article
regardless of who's making the statement
there's little evidence to support the
claim and a wide range of what can be
considered slavery as Braden Gerard
pointed out in a blog post historical
records of slavery do surprisingly
little to infor how many slaves there
once were at the same time organizations
disagree on what slavery means in a
modern context and no matter the
definition getting exact numbers is
nearly impossible sound of Freedom
positions Tim Ballard is an unabashed
hero working to save children and it
illustrates that he and his organization
operation Underground Railroad have been
undeniably effective in their work
however the real story is much more
complicated in 2020 Vice published an
investigation of Ballard and operation
Underground Railroad their report found
the organization has a long history of
obscuring the presentation of their work
for the public eye and that they have
made outright false claims operation
Underground Railroad or our releases
very few concrete details about the work
that it does or how it spends the
millions it receives in donations each
year the organization claims that it
needs to keep that information
confidential to continue being effective
but some of its most Sensational Rescue
Stories have turned out to be false
Ballard has repeatedly told stories
about our rescuing a child trafficking
victim called Liliana according to
Ballard Liliana was kidnapped as a young
teenager and sold into the sex trade
he's even used her story to argue that
there needs to be a border wall between
the U.S and Mexico Lily is often asked
me a simple yet powerful question
why was there no wall or barrier on the
southern border for me however when Vice
investigated it found that Liliana had
actually known her trafficker as is
common in these cases he was her
boyfriend at the time what's even more
surprising is that our didn't rescue
Liliana she escaped her trafficker
herself when she was 17 years old just
like sound of Freedom Ballard may be
well-intentioned but you might not want
to take every one of his claims at face
value if you or someone you know may be
the victim of child abuse please contact
the child help National child abuse
hotline at 1-800 for a child
1-800-422-4453 or contact their live
chat services
[Music]
thank you